[Musique]
la sortie beaucoup moins tendre qu'est
ce qui se passe mais chose est sûre
c'est que moi je le jure
qu'est ce qui s'passe métier n'esquisse
pas prises à temps des sites payants qui
le financent s'il vous plaît s'il vous
plaît s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
s'il vous plaît
qu'est ce qui se passe qu'est ce qui se
passe les chiffres ayant laissé laisser
les cdc qu'est ce qui se passe monsieur
qu'est ce qui se passe
donnez lui a donné lieu à un micro s'il
vous plaît qu'est ce qui se passe mieux
qu'est ce qui se passe au dessus de ce
qu'on pouvoir avoir un micro mme antier
vous plaît merci mon chéri qu'est ce qui
se passe dans le public oui merci
on est venu là pour juste faire du
scandale
nous sommes des maîtres d'hôtels d'accor
voilà une reprise on tourne les
précaires de les extras en l'occurrence
aujourd'hui pour la plupart sont des rsa
le mois prochain on sera le double au
rsa c'est vrai qu'on voit des images on
l'a vu des villages complètement
dévastée bien sûr mais bon ça va ou
intervenir on a préféré laisser ça on
pourra revenir après ça n'empêche pas
qu'il ya des gens dans la exactement on
comprend parfaitement la douleur mais la
douleur ont là aussi je ne veux pas
faire une comparaison et la douleur on
l'a aujourd'hui éolien au quotidien
alors quel est votre message dit moi le
message simplement c'est qu'aujourd'hui
les intermittents du spectacle ont été
reconduits dans leurs droits
un nom jusqu'en 2020 tient jusqu'en août
2000 watts est en nous je ne sais pas
pourquoi on est on nous a sortis du
système
aujourd'hui nous fonctionner comme des
intermittents du spectacle nous avons
nous faisons de l'événementiel vos
cocktails tout les les crs allons enfin
tout ce qui est que celle-ci concerne
avec ces mêmes les lélés les cocktails
de gouvernement c'est nous qu'ils en
l'occupant et aujourd'hui on nous a
totalement lâché
nous n'avons plus rien des journaux
depuis mars 2019
nous n'avons plus rien nous n'avons plus
d'argent nous nous sommes tous au rsa je
comprends tout à fait votre voix votre
souci je me sens très ému oui carrément
on peut c'est vraiment vraiment et
croyez moi c'est un drame social
vraiment ces confessions au salon michel
michel moi je comprends tout à fait on
sait qu'il ya plein de gens qui sont en
détresse ici on essaie vraiment de
parler voilà on était les premiers à
parler plein de choses ici c'est très
bien voilà votre action la prochaine
fois je vous jure n'hésitez pas à venir
me
c'était ça au départ on voulait vous
vraiment des altercations avec les
services de sécurité qui était déjà très
solide en mai j'ai dit on l'a dit je
savais qu'en ce moment
voilà c'est on peut pas faire du
spectacle verte est on est on est
vivants en alerte on en alerte au niveau
sécurité donc le service de sécurité et
fait malheureusement son travail et pour
eux et c'est pour ça que voilà on
comprendre tout à fait dans leur appel
on a pas on n'a aucune action ni
violence on veut dire on veut enfin
montrer puisque jusqu'à maintenant nous
avons un métier de discrétion nous
visons les destins jeu c'est le seul
départ je sais que vous n'êtes pas
entendu parce que voilà venez vous
n'êtes pas dans le dos dans le champ
d'action et c'est bien d'en parler ce
soir la tempe a signalé cette émission
c'est qu'on nous entende donne la parole
tu te feras dans btp jeudi soir il ya
aucun soutien vous redonnera la parole
est ce que vous vous engagez elle va
recevoir jeudi soir pour qu'on discute
mais c'est que je joue le panu avant
l'heure qui a quand même deux personnes
qui sont très importantes qui ont des
choses à dire et bae dont on les
écoutera jeudi soir dans btp en tout cas
merci avec plusieurs merci désolé mais
la sécurité ils ont paniqué
essentiellement ils font leur travail et
si si vous arrivez à moi et vous prenez
une micro et que vous intervenez dans
l'émission parfaitement qu'ils
n'interviennent
là forcément c'est sur eux que ça va
retomber c'est bien aussi il attendit
roman les mecs quand on fait ce genre
d'opération on est on est conscient de
ce qui va se passer on le fait sur la
fresque ont fourni la prochaine fois
vraiment je vous le dis n'hésitez pas à
venir me voir directement même à sortir
ou demandé à mes équipes et on peut
casser à l'apparence abed-salam sur le
moment ça à pied on pensait que de toute
façon ça n'est pas grave michel en série
comme ça et on va essayer d'avancer
l'invitation pour jeudi soir prochain au
jeudi soir là ce jeudi ce temps là on
vous écoutera avec plaisir qu'on sait
quelque chose
merci michel un pétard